Законопроєкт про протидію дезінформації, телеканал для тимчасово окупованих територій,
виступи українських артистів в Росії  та інші важливі теми
сьогодні обговорюємо з міністром культури, молоді та спортом Володимиром Бородянським.
Хотілося б почати з теми, яка наразі є чи не найактуальнішою,
принаймні для медіа середовища, це закопроєкт про протидію дезінформації.
Яким чином Ви особисто можете гарантувати,
що під виглядом боротьби з фейками не почнеться переслідування журналістів
і накладання цензури на ЗМІ?
Як ми і обіцяли, а ми обіцяли це постійно,
що ми не будемо вносити цей закон до того,
поки він не пройде суспільне обговорення.
І як ви знаєте, два тижні тому була вже перша стратегічна сесія
після представлення закону.
На наступному тижні почне роботу
робоча група з медіаюристів, яка почне пункт за пунктом опрацьовувати закон.
І ми вважаємо, що за 2 місяці ми запропонуємо суспільству
новий, оновлений текст закону,
який буде більш потужним.
Він ніяким чином не повинен
обмежувати журналістську діяльність щодо
таких елементів, як розслідувальна журналістика, щодо
критичних висловлювань  і критики влади і таке інше.
Наше завдання в цьому закон було убезпечити
українських громадян від дезінформації,
від можливості маніпулювання суспільною думкою,
яке може призвести до
спотворення суспільної думки і до загроз національній безпеці.
Ви медіаменеджер з величезним досвідом,
як на Вас впливає ця критика від колег, яка на вас навалилася в оці останні місяці?
І чи не боїтеся Ви, що якщо закопроект буде прийнятий
тому вигляді, в якому він є зараз, увійти в історію як людина,
яка якимось чином сприяла цензурі?
Ми розуміємо, що закон не буде прийняти в тому вигляді, в якому він є зараз.
А він буде прийнятий в іншому вигляді.
Друге,
я мало чого боюсь,
тому що я вірю в те, що я роблю.
Я розумію усі наслідки своєї роботи.
І завдання, яке стоїть переді мною і перед командою, зробити так,
щоб цей закон було неможливо використовувати в інший спосіб, ніж це передбачено.
Цим законом передбачено позбавлення волі для журналістів від 2 до 7 років,
гігантські штрафи для медіа, якщо вони багаторазово порушили цей закон,
виправні роботи для журналістів.
Такі покарання, на вашу думку, вони дійсно сприятимуть тому,
що фейків глобально в інформаційному просторі стане менше?
І яким чином контролюватиметься контент в соцмережах,
тому що є не журналісти, є лідери громадських думок, є блогери,
є дуже популярні телеграм-канали.
Що з цими джерелами інформації?
Покарання передбчаене за систематичне порушення закону,
систематичне – це три і більше разів.
Більше того, повинно бути винесено три вироки суду щодо того,
що ця інформація була дезінформацією
і що люди, які її розповсюджували,
систематично,  тобто протягом року порушували закон.
Тобто це не така проста історія, просто взяти когось і посадити.
Увязнення передбачено цим законом тільки за фінансування дезінформації,
тобто за свідоме фінансування і друге – за організацію ботоферм.
Щодо розповсюдження дезінформації, там немає ув’язнень,
там є суспільно-корисні роботи, не виправні, а корисні.
Але це кримінальна стаття.
Чи вважаю я це запобіжником? Так, вважаю.
Тобто Ви за такі жорсткі заходи?
Країна, проти якої здійснюється військова агресія, повинна захищати свій простір.
Там є багато запобіжників,
щоб це неможна було використовувати наліво й направо.
Я не говорю, що ми не можемо якісб елементи змінювати,
але покарання повинне бути відчутним, особливо в період війни.
Що з блогерами, лідерами думок, телеграм каналами?
Вони ж не несуть відповідальності за перепощування?
Вони не несуть за перепощування віповідальності,
але є першоджерело, яке несе відповідальність.
Якщо першоджерелу винесено попередження, що це дезінформація,
далі йде по ланцюгу, що ця інформація
може бути помічена як та, що є дезінформацією.
Ми будуємо такий правовий конструкт,
який дозволить нам звертатися, в тому числі, і в міжнародні суди
щодо відстоювання свого права на своїй території
застосовувати санкції до телеграм-каналів чи до будь-яких інших каналів,
які  розповсюджують дезінофрмацію.
Назвемо це законодавство екологічним щодо інформаційної сфери.
Воно починає розвиватися от зараз, з початком гібридних війн.
Межа між просто неправдивою інформацією і такою, що загрожує національній безпеці,
вона з одного боку зрозуміла, з іншого боку абстрактна.
Ми завжди повинні дивитися і суд буде дивитися,
яку це причинило шкоду суспільству і суспільним інституціям.
На вашу думку, суди зараз здатні
дати цю об’єктивну оцінку,
яка шкода була завдана чи дійсно була небезпека?
У нас є такі суди, які є,
і треба напрацьовувати таку практику,
щоб це було максимально
зрозумило громадянам і суспільству.
Ми хворіємо і ми лікуємось.
І це шлях, на якому ми стоїмо.
Ми вилікуємось, обов’язково.
Хотілося б поговорити ще інформаційну інтеграцію тимчасово окупованих територій,
ну власне, про цей телеканал, який має мовити для людей,
які живуть на непідконтрольних територіях.
Вже відомо, що в його запуску
бере активну участь режисер слуги народу Олексій Кирющенко,
і подейкують, що значна частина контенту буде теж виробництва 95 кварталу.
Чи не стане це в такому форматі якимось рупором "Слуги народу"
і просто джерелом збагачення для продакшену президента?
Кирющенко приймає участь, я про це казав.
Це правдивий факт. В нас є домовленість
з телевізійним групами України про те, що вони будуть надавати
свій найкращий контент безкоштовно цьому телеканалу.
Це перше. Безкоштовно! Ніхто збагачуватися не буде.
руге, медіагрупа «Україна» погодилася передавати такий ексклюзивний продукт,
як футбольні матчі, які йдуть на телеканалі включно з матчами «Шахтаря».
Тому там будуть різні продукти різних медіагруп.
І немає ніякого плану, що це буде монотелеканал
якогось одного продукту.
Зараз іде формування сітки. Мови буде дві – українська й російська.
Завдання цього каналу донести правду.
Правду про Україну. Правду.
Ви вважаєте, що люди які там, якщо це буде звернено на молодь в тому числі,
що вони не мають  доступу до правди?
Вони ж мають доступ до Ютуба.
Вони мають доступ до маніпуляцій зі сторони російских телеканалів,
до потужного механізму  маніпуляцій.
Включаєш телевізор і ти бачиш постійно одне й те саме, тих самих експертів,
які говорять, наратив у Росії, що Україна це недодержава.
Є в росіян таке.
Безумовно, це впливає на людей.
Ми повинн розказати правду про себе, сказати ясно про те,
як буде відбуватися реігнтеграція Донбасу,
розказати про правосуддя перехідного періоду.
Вони повинні зрозуміти, чого прагне Україна
і що вона не прагне війни, вона прагне миру.
Як зробити так, щоб люди в цю правду повірили
після того, як вони 6 років живуть в неправді?
ніякими продуктами не можна зробити, щоби люди повірили
легко перейшли від неправди в правду.
Це комплекс заходів,
це те, що ми говоримо, це те, як ми діємо.
Ми відповідаємо за телеканал,
ми, як ви знаєте, запускаємо програму обміну молоддю.
Ми будемо залучати молодь, яка проживає на тих територіях зі всіма безпековими аспектами,
щоб вона подивилася на Україну, яка вона.
Вони вже давно не бачили Україну, які ми.
Всі ці міри направлені на те, щоб вони зрозуміли,
що Україна розвивається як сучасна цивілізація,
яка прагне жити в сучасному світі і бути частиною цього світу.
Ми будемо налагоджувати діалог з тими інстутуціями
науковими, освітніми,
які готові будуть вести діалог
і для яких це буде безпечно також.
Ми повинні почати діалог людина-людина з українцями,
які там зараз проживають.
Мається на увазі почати говорити в ефірі
обговорювати проблематику, яка є
і ті побоювання, які є.
Нам і їм і всім Україні необхідна ясність.
В мене питання щодо технічного боку цього телеканалу.
Я припускаю, що блокуватимуть усіма можливими і неможливими способами
це мовлення.
Чи готові ви до цього і як діятимете?
У нас є технічні тести і ми вважаємо,
що знаємо, як діяти.
Побачимо вживу. Це буде зрозуміло, коли прийдуть конкретні проблеми вже.
Цього тижня телеканал АТР заявив про загрозу закриття через те,
що вони не можуть отримати бюджетне фінансування, яке було їм виділене.
ка позиція міністерства з цього приводу, адже виглядає трохи нелогічно –
ми відкриваємо канал для тимчасово окупованих територій
при цьому не може мовити канал кримськотатарською мовою.
Міністерство робить все можливе, щоб
кримськотатарський канал мовив.
Збільшено фінансування,
було 35 млн минулого року, цього року 50 млн.
Ми провели перемовини з самим каналом і з Меджилісом,
щоб Меджиліс долучити до роботи по кримськотатарському мовленню.
Проблема, яка виникла, вона виникла через те,
що державне казначейство і телеканал по-різному трактують
поточне законодавство щодо публічних закупівель.
Ми теж з цим працюємо, багато зусттрічей проводимо,
консультацій з держказначейством, з іншими органами влади,
ми працюємо з цим.
Є от така суперечка законодавча.
В останньому інтерв’ю ви сказали про те,
що не схвалюєте виступи українських артистів в Росії,
але при цьому не підтримуєте якісь заборони чи механізму впливу на це.
Розкажіть, як це сприймати.
Я вважаю, що культура, культурний продукт,
оли наші артисти їздять виступати,
це нормує наші відносини з Росією.
Я вважаю, що це неприпустимо в ситуації,
коли йде війна, нормування відносин.
Я також казав, що
ми не знайшли зараз механізмів, які були б дієвими
з точки зору обмеження таких поїздок.
Це сьогодні етичний вибір кожного артиста.
Для мене це поза ...
за межею добра і зла
Колись була ідея позбавити Повалій, Лорак, Лободу звання народних артистів.
Ви як це сприймаєте?
Я взагалі ці звання сприймаю, як посткомуністичне минуле.
Я би взагалі їх всі відмінив. Так я це сприймаю.
Торкнемося питання мови – за півроку запрацює офіс мовного омбудсмена,
а наразі ми бачимо таку ситуацію, коли на прохання волонтерок
вимкнути російський фільм в маршрутці,
вони отримали позов від депутата в тому, що вони
що вони ініціюють дискримінацію і розпалювання ворожнечі. Прокоментуйте, будь ласка, це.
Це не просто волонтерка, це дівчина, яка поверталась з похорон хлопця,
що загинув в зоні військових дій.
Я взагалі вважаю, що тут не може бути і питань з приводу того,
що цей фільм чи серіал російський потрібно було вимкнути.
Це настільки очевидно і настільки
не потребує ніяких обговорень,
що мені просто немає що додати до цього.
Але тепер є позов до них фактично з захистом цього російськогомовного контенту.
Дурня,
дурний позов, дурний вчинок, неправильний.
Тоді з огляду на це, як Ви ставитеся до проекту закону,
запропонованого В'ятровичем так званого проти аудіовізуального насилля
у громадському транспорті,
щоби взагалі заборонити будь-яку музику, будь-які фільми в громадському транспорті?
Я не читав закон, мені складно сказати, як я до нього відношуся,
я ще про це не думав.
Але загалом до ініціативи, що проти волі
людина не має слухати півгодини чи годину щось?
З тим, що вона не має проти волі щось слухати – так,
але я не знаю, який механізм повинен діяти.
Я просто не читав законпроект. Мені складно відреагувати.
Якщо ви сідаєте в таксі в Мюнхені,
там завжди грає класична музика.
Ви можете попросити її вимкнути, але іншої я не чув скільки їжджу.
Може, на перший погляд, здаватися не найважливішим,
але коли можна очікувати, що з цирків все-таки зникнуть тварини?
Зараз розробляється законопроект
щодо заборони викорстання тварин в видовищах,
не тільки в цирках, а для будь-яких розваг,
не спортивних, не лікувальних, а саме видовищних.
Ця дискусія йде з фахівцями,
народними депутатами і цей закон буде прийнятий.
Щодо позиції міністерства, ми написали циркам,
що є в нашому управлінні, це державні цирки,
що за 2020 рік ми повинні перейти
на модель цирків без тварин.
Те, що можу сказати, що з 2021 року
тварини не будуть використовуватися для розваг.
Що з ними буде з цими тваринами?
Ми підписали меморандум про співпрацю
з "Фельдман-екопарком",
який погодився на безкоштовних умовах прийняти всіх тварин на реабілітацію
І ми працюємо з іншими людьми, які також будуть готові це зробити.
Ви очолюєте об’єднане міністерство і от нещодавно з’являлися думки
від Гончарука, від президента,
що можливо треба розділити його знову на культури та спорту окремо.
Чи не є це показником неефективності
і як ви ставитеся до такого розподілу, наскільки, на Вашу думку, він буде доречним?
Ми півроку об’єднували міністерства
і на сьогоднішній день об’єднання практично завершене…
Інституційно
це буде набагато, в рази потужніше ніж те, що було до цього
У нас напередодні олімпіада,
і завдання міністерства вибудувати таку систему фінансування
всіх заходів, щоб все йшло точно за графіком.
Розділення міністерств відкине нас
ще мінімум на рік,
тобто вся ця робота вона розпочнеться заново через рік.
Тому я вважаю, що інституційно
це правильне рішення,
якщо є зауваження до ефективності роботи міністерства
інституційно треба залишати, треба змінювати людей, які не впоралися.
Вам не висловлювали незадоволення чи якусь претензію,
що це неефективно чи не впоралися?
Поки що ні, але ще раз повторюсь –
для нас, для мене особисто це вибір піти працювати
в команду реформування і зміни парадигми розвитку.
Все, більше ніяких причин не було.
Ще не розчарувалися? Півроку минуло.
Та хто ж за півроку розчаровується?
Це неймовірний виклик
і неймовірно цікава робота.
Це точно вартувало, це складно,
але цього вартувало. Ми віримо в наш результат.
Ми віримо, що ми зробимо суттєві зміни.
Просто не всі зміни можна відчути відразу.
Дуже дякую!
Дякую